The models have reached a point where
they have surpassed my ability to really
understand what they're capable of. The
sense that I get from talking to people
that are more familiar with the space is
that the models are extremely good at
combining a lot of different areas of
mathematics. It's arguable that they're
not superhuman yet, but we're also
seeing rapid progress on that side. But
over time it will just become superhuman
in basically every respect. And I don't
know how long that transition period is
going to take. It could be It could be a
couple of years. It could be could be 10
years, but I think we'll get there
eventually.
>> Welcome to the Game Theory.
I'm Slater with Bain Capital Ventures,
and today we're talking with Noam Brown.
At OpenAI, Noam focuses on multi-agent
reasoning and test time compute scaling.
He was one of the key people behind O1,
OpenAI's first public reasoning model.
Last year his team swept [music] the
math and CS contest circuit. Their model
won gold medals at the IMO, IOI, and
ICPC.
Today we'll talk about OpenAI's recent
disproof of the Erdős unit distance
conjecture and about AI for math
research in general.
Noam, thanks for coming today.
>> Of course. I'm great to be I'm happy to
be here.
>> Well, you know, we're so we're sitting
here today. It's about a week after
OpenAI announced
you sort of
disproof of this Erdős conjecture
on the planar unit distance problem. And
it's the first thing that I want to talk
about. And you know, maybe my first
question is why is this happening now?
You know, I think the IMO results, which
are already incredibly very incredibly
impressive, happened about 10 months
ago.
You know, sort of why are we seeing the
first sort of major results in math
research today as opposed to 10 months
ago? What's the different about the
models or the systems?
>> I mean, in many ways it's it's not that
surprising. When we got the IMO result
about a year ago, we expected You know,
we said that progress is going to
continue, that we'll see um
more significant results in math. And
eventually we're going to reach a point
where the models are proving things that
humans can't prove. And there were some
initial like signs like this over the
over the course of the year when the
model started proving things that were
unproven. Um, I think there were
questions around like, well, was that
just because humans hadn't paid much
attention to it or was it doing things
that were just like, you know, not that
interesting. And um,
I think what's cool about this result is
like it's it's perhaps the first case of
like a model proving something that was
like really interesting to
mathematicians and also a very
significant problem. And we we kind of
felt like this was going to happen
eventually and it just, you know, the
models kept becoming more capable and
um,
it just finally happened. And I should
say this wasn't like,
you know, it wasn't like me or my team
that like enabled this result. It's just
a natural consequence of the models
becoming more capable.
Um, and then, you know, some researchers
at OpenAI decided to like, okay, well,
is this at now at the level where it can
actually prove a problem like this? And
they ran it on that problem and it
turned out the answer was yes.
>> Yeah.
Were you um, one thing I wanted to ask
about is sort of like domains in math
that you think are you're sort of most
optimistic about? Do you feel like
combinatorics is an area where, you
know, you were especially interested or
you felt like rapid progress um, with AI
was sort of more possible or, you know,
sort of is it that behind the scenes
you're sort of trying lots and lots of
open problems and this just happened to
be the one
um, that fell first?
>> Yeah, I don't think there's anything um,
special about combinatorics. I don't
think I mean, basically I'm a result of
anything I was like a little bit bearish
on combinatorics.
>> Yeah.
>> But um,
it it just it just so happened that
yeah, we just tried a bunch of different
problems and this one the answer came
back like, oh yeah, it seems like this
one's correct.
>> Yeah.
Well, one thing I was interested in is
um, you know, the construction itself
and it looks it's it's very interesting
because it's the kind of thing that I
think a human mathematician would have
really struggled um, to come up with.
Um, you know, it's a very complicated
construction. It has like some analogies
to the original um, Erdos argument, but
it's it's quite a lot more complex. And
you know, you guys released this kind of
companion piece with commentary from
mathematicians on the results. And
you know, I think it was Jacob Zimmerman
who had remarks of like, man, you know,
I tried something like this a while ago,
but it just was sort of too complicated.
You know, sort of the waters were too
treacherous, I think was his phrase. And
it sort of raises this interesting
question about whether
AI systems are going to be better at
math in ways that are really different
than humans. Like they sort of might be
maxed out in different dimensions.
In other words, you know, in the
specific case, like maybe
even a human mathematician given the
prompt of try to find a counter example
to this might never come across this.
And I am curious for your commentary on
that. Do you kind of feel as though the
models are better at math in a way
that's different from humans as opposed
to saying being like a human, but just,
you know, some factor some factor
better.
>> You know, it's interesting like the
models have reached a point where they
have surpassed my ability to really
understand
what they're capable of and like what
they excel at just because like already
the you know, these kinds of problems
like understanding the proofs so is just
beyond my ability. I'm sure it's beyond
most people's ability, but it's also
beyond my ability. And
so it's hard for me at this point to say
like, oh yeah, these are like the weak
points of the models and this these are
like the strong points of the models in
the field of math.
But I
the sense that I get from talking to
people that are more familiar with the
space
both at OpenAI and external
mathematicians is that the models are
extremely good at combining a lot of
different areas of mathematics.
And they're also like in this in this
respect I would say that they're
superhuman at this point.
>> Yeah.
>> And then there's the separate question
of like reasoning through the the the
complex problems. And this I think like
the argument it's arguable that they're
not superhuman yet, but we're also
seeing rapid progress on this. And so I
think we're going to see this kind of
spiky intelligence where
um
the models are going to be superhuman in
some respects and then also not quite
superhuman in other respects and the
point but over time as the models become
more capable they are going to become
like more capable across the board and
that's what we're seeing. It's that it's
not just like oh they're getting better
and better at ingesting a lot of
mathematics and combining it. It's that
they're getting better at that but
they're also getting better at just like
the fundamental reasoning capabilities.
So
I
I think we will in the short term see
more of these more more results where
it's like
combining different areas of mathematics
and in novel ways that that nobody
thought to do before and then
having it be like really cool proofs in
this kind of way
but over time it will just become
superhuman in basically every respect.
And I don't know how long that
transition period is going to take. It
could be it could be a couple of years,
it could be could be 10 years
um
but I think we'll get there eventually.
>> Yeah. What do you That is one thing I
was curious about is if you speculate
that there is this kind of like centaur
period for sort of like human
aided math or you know if you think that
that period is too short to be sort of
interesting in the long run. Curious
what you think about that.
>> Yeah, I think there there definitely
will be a centaur period and this
the classic analogy which I think is
appropriate is to things like chess and
go where in chess
you have Garry Kasparov losing to Deep
Blue in like 1997 and then there is this
like 10-year period where
okay chess AIs were better in some ways
but you know they weren't like the human
plus the AI was actually better than the
human alone or or an AI alone.
And at this point the AIs are so good at
chess that like
the human doesn't really add anything
and so it's like clear that it is beyond
the human's ability to add anything to
the to the table. Um but
and and I think we'll see something
similar with mathematics where okay the
AIs are like extremely effective in some
ways but they're not and and we might
reach a point where they're just like if
you had a choice between a human
mathematician or an AI mathematician,
you would choose the AI mathematician.
But even when we reach that point, you
could argue that the human plus the AI
would be more effective than either
alone.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, how long that period is, it's hard
to say. It it
it could be very short, it could be it
could be long. I I think a lot of it
depends on
uh on the trajectory of mathematical
progress. I think also this is where the
analogy to things like chess and Go
break down because chess and Go became
superhuman because of self-play and the
ability of the AI to just like
get collect infinite data and like play
against itself and get arbitrarily
better. And we don't really have a
similar version of self-play in
mathematics because it's not a
two-player zero-sum game.
So,
you it could take longer for the
capabilities to improve. Now, that said,
I mean also the capabilities have been
improving very rapidly and so I don't
know, it's a trade it's like kind of a
trade-off. It's kind of I'm trying to
balance the fact that like AI progress
has been extremely fast so far um versus
the fact that like there is the
possibility that
progress slows down as you reach
superhuman capabilities.
>> Yeah, I've um you would know much more
than me, but I sort of heard like
speculations around the self-play idea
of like, you know, you should have
someone propose one model proposes
problems, the other tries to solve them.
You can kind of adversarially make the
problems more difficult in some way, but
maybe it's it's like very hard to get to
work. It's it seems way clear less clear
how you would do that than in like a
like a sort of very um sort of boxed
setting like a like playing Go.
>> Yeah, this is like
I think people under appreciate how
unique two-player zero-sum games are
when it comes to self-play. Like in in
these two-player zero-sum games, you
have a very clear objective, which is
you want to converge to a minimax
policy. And you can do like you just
have the AIs play against each other.
You don't need any external data. You
don't need any human data.
Just have the AIs play against each
other and figure out how to beat each
other and then learn from those mistakes
and they will converge to the minimax
policy.
When you go outside of a two-player
zero-sum game, you don't have this
property anymore. So, an example I like
to give is the ultimatum game. Are you
familiar with the ultimatum game?
>> No.
>> Okay, so the ultimatum game, it's a
non-two-player zero-sum game.
One player, Alice, has $100 and they
have to choose how much to give to Bob.
They can offer anywhere between $0 and
$100.
>> Mhm.
>> And Bob chooses to reject or accept.
>> And if Bob rejects, then both players
receive $0. If Bob accepts, then the
money is split according to what Alice
proposed. So, like let's say Alice
offers 20 bucks.
>> Right.
>> Bob accepts, then Alice gets 80, Bob
gets 20. And then if Bob rejects, then
they both get zero.
>> Mhm.
>> And so,
you know, you could imagine what
self-play would converge to in this
game. If you had to guess, like what
what do you think it would converge to?
>> Like always accepting.
>> Yeah, always accepting and then like
Alice offering basically like a dollar
or something or a penny.
>> Yeah.
>> If you were to do this with humans, it
would not go very well, right? Like if I
were to offer you like, okay, I have 100
bucks, I'm going to offer you a penny.
You have a choice of accepting or
rejecting. Like
>> Yeah.
>> how would you react?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I would
>> So,
so like once you go outside of
two-player zero-sum games, this this
idea of like self-play converging to
this like beautiful, elegant, like
perfect strategy that is objectively
correct no longer holds.
>> Yeah.
>> And you run into a similar problem with
things like math. You know, you could
say like, okay, we'll do self-play in
mathematics where like one agent is
trying to propose arbitrarily difficult
problems and then the other agent is
trying to solve them.
The problem is the proposer agent could
for example propose
>> Right.
>> impossible problems.
>> Yeah.
>> Or they could propose problems that are
like difficult but not but difficult in
a way that's not interesting to humans.
So, for example, it could be like
50-digit multiplication. Like, yeah,
that's going to be difficult for an LLM
to do if it doesn't have a calculator,
but is it interesting? Like, not really.
>> Yeah, it's very hard to regularize,
right? Like, even things where there's a
short solution or sort of like a known
solution, it's hard to come up with
problems of the sort that um like would
sort of push you in the right direction
for training.
>> Yeah.
So, it's not to say that self-play can't
work. I think I think self-play is going
to
be extremely important, and I think it
will
probably be the thing that propels us
past superhuman performance to just
like, you know, unimaginable levels of
like of intelligence for for these
models.
But, it's not as easy as it
was done for for Go and chess and these
two-player zero-sum games. And that And
that's the main reason why it's unclear
to me how long the Centaur period will
be because I think it depends a lot on
how long does it take to like really
unlock self-play in a proper way.
>> Super interesting. Well, coming back to
um the Erdős problem for a minute, you
said something um
a little bit ago that was really
interesting, which was um
you know, the models uh have gotten so
good that it's sort of hard for
non-expert humans to sort of tell
whether a solution is correct or not.
And so, I was curious like at a micro
level what this specific result was
like. You know, I imagine that you guys
have some automated testing and maybe
like a team of in-house mathematicians.
But, uh you know, I've I'm just sort of
curious like about the play-by-play of,
you know, we think that we have a
solution to this problem, and um what
does it take to actually sort of, you
know, believe that we've we've gotten
all the way there?
>> Yeah, and basically what happened was we
trained a new model. Um
and it wasn't designed for math or
anything. It wasn't um it's a
general-purpose reasoning model.
And um afterwards, I mean, we have
people with, you know, math PhDs at
OpenAI, some people that were formerly
math professors that um are interested
in math. And they just decided like kind
of as a as a side thing, like, "Okay,
well, let's let's see where the
capabilities of this new model are.
Let's run it on a bunch of unsolved
problems and just see like if any of
them
you know, if if it thinks that any of
them are correct. And of course like one
of the challenges is like actually
verifying these things. So So basically
the model was so they ran it through a
bunch of problems um and this is one of
the problems where it came back and said
like actually um it's it's solved. Um
and then there's like this very
difficult process of like verifying that
that's correct because you know, you
need not just an expertise in math but
like an expertise in several areas of
math in order to determine that it's
actually correct. So this is like
actually pretty interesting week-long
period where like we they thought it was
correct but like they weren't really
sure.
Um
And so they had to like go to a bunch of
external mathematicians and discuss like
okay, well, we have this candidate
proof. Can you like help us figure out
if this is actually a valid proof?
>> Yeah.
>> Um
And then like yeah, like once it became
clear like okay, this is actually
correct, there's a question of like what
to do. Um
and you know, honestly like for me, you
know, they they told me like yeah, you
know, we think this model like prove
this result and I'm like okay, what does
that mean? Like I don't I don't know.
I don't know if this is actually a big
deal. Like you know, I heard about like,
you know, dozens of Erdős problems being
solved before. Like why is this one
different? Um but I I think it
what would really helped convince me and
I think I think a lot of people was
getting the um
talking to the external mathematicians
and and hearing from them that like
actually this is a very significant
result.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
and and and so yeah, that was basically
the the trajectory of things. So that's
also why we put a big emphasis on like
getting the feedback from the
mathematicians um these external
mathematicians because
it it's one thing for us to say that
this is a significant result. I think
it's another thing to say for external
mathematicians to say that it's a
significant result.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I agree. I mean, I think
it's something that um you know, like I
remember hearing about this result um as
an undergrad and um it's it's certainly
like in the flavor of things where
mathematicians spend a lot of time, you
know, sort of working on it. It's not
like one of these areas that's been
attention starved.
Um
and
and yet I think like this approach like
it's probably received like very little
attention.
Um
and
you know, I think that's one of the
things interesting about AI models is um
you could potentially like pour a level
of of sort of attention and effort into
these problems that sort of like far
exceeds, you know, sort of even human
society's capacity to work on them. Like
so many areas in math might only have a
couple of people working at the absolute
forefront and so it's easy to imagine
kind of like a nearer time field when um
the vast majority of the effort, just
measured by like hours of time spent on
these problems, comes from AI systems as
opposed from human mathematicians. And
I've wondered if, you know, that alone
should actually propel a lot of
discovery.
>> I think that could be the case. And but
one one thing I want to emphasize is
that we did not put a lot of effort into
solving this problem. Like it was not a
lot of compute at the end of the day.
Uh we later like showed this plots
where, you know, the x-axis is the
amount of test time compute and the
y-axis is like the probability of
solving the Erdos problem. And like to
put that in perspective, to make that
plot, we had to run the model on the
problem 100 times for every single data
point.
>> Yeah.
>> And so like if we're doing that 100 runs
for every single data point on that
plot, it's like okay, you you you can
kind of get a sense. It's not the most
expensive thing.
Now
one of the really cool things from that
plot was that we showed as you put more
test time compute into uh solving the
problem, the probability of solving it
goes up pretty pretty significantly. And
I mean, my takeaway from that is like
there is
uh probably a bunch of other problems
that we have not solved that this model
can solve. And we just haven't put the
amount of compute into it that's
necessary.
>> Yeah.
Are there any areas you're a
optimistic about sort of like, you know,
given this result, you should all have a
belief update that, you know, sort of
like true sort of like annals of
mathematics level um you sort of novel
discoveries are possible. Um you sort of
have this new instrument. Um you know,
where do you want to point it?
>> It's a good question. I mean, the truth
is
for
we
at OpenAI like have a huge amount of
leverage to make the models more
effective. And
we're in this weird spot where like we
have we have access to these frontier
models like
a few months before anybody else does.
And it's really tempting to then go
through all of the unsolved mathematical
problem mathematics problems and and try
to run the model on them and try to see
what can be proven and what can't be
proven and to spend basically all of our
time doing that because we can get some
incredible results. Um
but I don't think that is actually the
highest
highest leverage for us. Like I think
the highest leverage for us
is making the models better, more
powerful,
uh safer, getting them out to the world
as quickly as possible, and enabling
mathematicians to use these models to
solve all of these unsolved problems.
So, for us
I I it's really tempting to to try to
solve all these problems and I actually
try to discourage um
researchers that I work with at OpenAI
from from going down that route because
I think that the most important thing is
for us to focus on improving the models
themselves.
And that's actually what I'm most
bullish about. I mean, I I the fact that
this was not a math-specific result,
that this was not a math-specific model
uh or or algorithm or anything, um it
was just a general-purpose model.
It's not
the capabilities are not limited to
mathematics. So, I think it's also
um going to be very effective at doing
things like machine learning research
and
and making the models more effective and
enabling us to basically do recursive
self-improvement.
>> Yeah, I remember um I think you were one
of the first people that I talked to
that really believed in this idea of
using the general purpose reasoning
models for these types of things. Like
so for contest math, for example, I
think like a year ago there was this big
debate of, you know, do you have to go
through the sort of lean formalization
path? You know, can you use a general
purpose reasoning model? If I remember
correctly, the model that you guys used
for all of the contests, like uh IMO,
IOI, ICPC, was effectively the same
model, if I'm remembering correctly.
>> Basically the same model. I I think for
ICPC and IOI it was like um a scaffold
of a few models, um but the most
important model was like the same model
as was used in the IMO.
>> And so um why why was that so important
to you? Is this this feeling of like I
want these improvements to be generally
useful for things like recursive
self-intelligence, uh self-improvement?
Um is it that, you know, you sort of you
cared about sort of transfer from these
sort of contest domains to the model
that, you know, hundreds of millions of
people use every day? Um you know, why I
think you were sort of very early to
sort of making that decision.
>> For me it it it was always, you know,
what what was extremely impactful was
like the the really general purpose
systems and
um trying to like
just break things down to the actual
bare minimum that's needed, um and then
and then figuring out what could be
scaled.
>> Mhm.
>> And so, especially at a time when like
the field is progressing so quickly,
it's it's really easy to get nerd sniped
into making these like custom-built
models that are
very, very good at, you know, solving
the IOI or whatever, um but ultimately
will not be useful 6 months down the
road.
>> Yeah.
>> And
I
I think it's important for us to
recognize that like
there is a goal, and that goal is like
AGI or superintelligence or whatever you
want to call it, and we don't want to
take detours from that route. And so
like I think it's I think it's great to
do things like the IMO as as a milestone
along the way to AGI, but I don't think
we want to get sidetracked by it too
much.
>> Right. It should be like a byproduct of
ascending the curve as opposed to, you
know, sort of putting resources just to
sort of claim claim the post.
>> Yeah. And it is it is a constant tension
because like there's such a temptation
to to get these really impressive
results
to
present it to the world and and get
recognition and all this stuff and
and we
we have to like resist that temptation,
I think.
>> Yeah.
So, if the path is sort of releasing the
models to human mathematicians, and and
so the idea being that, you know, they'd
be the ones that sort of spend time you
sort of playing with them and producing
producing these results.
You know, one thing I wondered about is
who's going to be really good at that
and if it's sort of different in any
ways than, you know, sort of the current
set of human, if you want, like manual
mathematicians.
And so like the analogy here is,
you know, Richard Hamming
had this interesting thing where he I
think he was like an early proponent of
simulations
in physics. And you know, he has this
thing where he's talking to the
president of Bell Labs and he's like,
you know, today like 90% of the
experiments are being done, you know,
sort of in the physical world and in the
lab and it's like 10% on the computer.
Like that's going to switch immediately.
It's going to be 90% on the computer and
maybe 10% in physical reality. Then he
goes on to kind of describe how like the
people who are really good in the sort
of, you know, simulation regime are not
necessarily the same people who are
really good in kind of the experimental
regime. Are the people who are going to
be really good at proving new math with
these models different than the people
who are really good at doing math
manually, so to speak? Like
should we expect, you know, lots of
impressive new results to come from like
Fields Medalists or should we predict
them to instead come from people who are
really really good at using these
models, which are maybe a different set
of people?
>> I think it's possible that it is a
different set of people. I think
It's a feel like this is always the case
with new technology where it requires
adapting and approaching things very
differently.
And um and it's also a question of
if the models are extremely good in some
respects
and below human performance in in other
then you want like the people that are
going to be most successful are the
people who are the complements to the
models.
>> Yeah.
>> So that profile could be very different
from what makes a great mathematician
today. It's a little hard to say because
I think it depends on I mean it depends
on like where the AI models are are
going to be strong and where they're
weak and what makes a great
mathematician today um
but I I think the people that will be
most successful
will be the people that complement the
AI models really well.
>> And do you see any early hints of who
those like what that might be? Like what
are the ways in which you know like one
thing I can imagine for instance is like
um math has become very specialized. You
know a lot of these domains people I
remember when I was an undergrad um you
know some I asked about this result and
I was like
is this this really important result
about elliptic curves and I said you
know if I really spend time trying to
understand it could I? And um
you know this sort of uh very well known
math professor is like well no because
um you know I spent like six months
trying to do it as a fifth year grad
student and like I don't feel like I
understood it. It's just sort of so
specialized. One thing I can imagine is
that like maybe the generalists have
like another you know sort of day in the
sun where connecting a lot of these
different areas is valuable. Another
thing I can imagine is it's like
totally different than that. It's it's
sort of like more about um
sort of point having intuition for where
the models are good and pointing on the
right problems. I'm just curious if you
have like any early hints of like you
know who who the sort of like new
mathematicians are. Like where are those
sort of complimentary skills?
>> I my personal experience is you know in
using these models to do AI research and
in my experience
they tend to not have very good research
taste.
And so for me this has actually been
been amazing. It's been amazing period
because like you know, I was like okay
at the
you know, the kind of like the IC kind
of work but it was I was never like
exceptional in this respect and now you
know, I I feel like I'm such a great
compliment to these models. I'm able to
be so much more productive. And um
I wouldn't be surprised if it's
something similar in mathematics where
the ability to ask the right questions
and know what to investigate becomes um
the most valuable thing because the
models probably not very good at that
right now.
And
I yes, I I I could see that being
people that are extremely good at that
might be a good compliment to the to the
AI models in math.
>> So maybe somebody who sort of has good
research taste and has is like good at
program construction. Like I'm going to
work on Langlands or I'm going to you
know, sort of like be Grothendieck
style. Like you have kind of like this
larger program that you know, sort of is
the right path to go down.
>> Mhm.
>> Um
interesting. You know, one thing I was
curious about is this kind of
construction
um you know, sort of versus versus sort
of like a different kind of argument for
the Erdős problem specifically. So in
your companion piece
the Field Medalist
Timothy Gowers you know, sort of has the
story where he says, you know, at first
he thought that what OpenAI had done was
sort of prove a much tighter upper
bound.
And then he said he sort of like really
lost a lot of sleep after that. Like if
that's true then like we're all
completely cooked you know, because that
that that sort of like I can't even
imagine how progress would be possible
there. And then you know, he says that
when he sort of learned that instead it
was that it was a sort of much it was um
you know, sort of the construction of a
of a counterexample
that sort of disprove that
you know, Erdős's upper bound.
You know, that felt to him like more
plausible. Like that was the kind of
thing that you could at least imagine
like an AI model coming up with. And I
guess I'm curious like if you would draw
that distinction like if there's any
anything that like you take from that,
like again, I'm
the spirit of this is the flavor of like
places where the models are going to be
better than humans.
Um,
you know, maybe I'm curious if you sort
of view that as like a real
philosophical distinction.
>> I mean, I
I think I would expect
separate from the Erdős problem, like if
I were to if I
were to
predict what the progress of AI in
mathematics would look like, I think it
would be, okay, you get something like
IMO gold, and then you start proving
some like unsolved
problems that aren't that, you know,
significant or that researchers haven't
paid much attention to. And then you get
to something like you prove a
significant res- like significant
result, but in a way that's like,
you know,
not,
um, you know, causing a field of
mathematicians to like lose sleep saying
like this is like beyond human ability
in like every respect.
And then the progress will continue, and
eventually you'll get to that point
where, you know, yeah, the
mathematicians do lose sleep. But I I
think it's just
natural to expect that this is the
progression of things, and we're just
seeing another point uh along that
progression.
And that's kind of what I would expect
from this level of capability, and a
year from now,
I think the capability would be much
higher, and I wouldn't be surprised if
it's like doing things that are
unimaginable to mathematicians today.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah, and it sort of already feels like,
um, I think a lot of the mathematician
commentary too is like, um,
this is such like a sort of deep way of
improving sort of the original
construction. Like there's sort of like
a very There's the original Erdős sort
of, you know, like
relatively elementary construction. To
improve it requires all of these
different ideas, um, from algebraic
number theory. And again, like the
number of people who sort of have all
those things in their head, and who
could sort of spend serious time in that
on the problem, um, um, is very small.
And so, you know, maybe like another way
that I've wondered about AI systems
having a major advantage, um, over
humans is this idea of, um,
you know,
the existing research literature is
vast. Um,
most professional mathematicians only
know like a small fraction of it. Um,
there are probably lots of problems
where if you, you know, sort of put five
papers in front of them and said like,
read these five papers, you know, you
can't leave this room, you know, and
sort of until you've proved some result
using them, um, you could make progress,
but you just can't do that for like many
different areas. And so, I I sort of
wondered about this idea of like this
kind of one-time dividend that we might
be very close to achieving where it's
like just sort of putting together ideas
from very different research areas to
produce something new. You maybe that's
one of the things that's more near
field. Um, and I'd be curious what you
think about that.
>> I do think that's going to be short-term
where a lot of these breakthroughs come
from. I mean, the fact that the model's
like trained on so much different on so
so many different data sources, so many
different papers, it it's able to
connect ideas that, I mean,
it's it's impossible to keep up with
like every single field in an in-depth
way. And so, this is already something
that it's pretty clear the models have
been superhuman for a while.
>> Mhm.
>> And, um,
and so, I do think that well, this is
where it begins.
And I think it just progresses from
there.
>> Maybe you're kind of bumping one level
up. Um,
you know, what are the reasons why you
think math is a particularly good
domain? Um, you know, sort of I'd put it
inside of AI for science sort of writ
large where sort of making new
scientific discovery, um, with AI
models. And, um,
you know, I'd I'd be curious for your
take on
if math is a particularly,
um, you know, sort of fertile domain for
doing this. And then sort of what other
domains you're optimistic about. Is it
inside of physics or particular sort of
uh sort of branch of physics? Maybe the
models are um, you know, sort of very
good at at sort of particle physics
problems or something. Curious for sort
of where you're most optimistic.
>> I think math is special because it is
purely bottlenecked by reasoning.
>> Mhm.
>> Like in in physics, my impression, I
don't know I'm not a physicist, so I
don't know for sure, but talking to
physicists, it sounds like a lot of the
field is bottlenecked by experimental
results at this point. And so, you know,
you could you could make all sorts of
crazy theories, but
ultimately you need to put a bunch of
money into the actual physical
experiments to be able to validate them
or get more data to inform like what the
next steps are. And you don't really
have that problem with mathematics. You
can just sit in a room and think for a
really hard for a long time and come up
with something like amazing and that's
how you make progress.
And um
And so, I think we'll see the biggest
benefits in the short term from these
kinds of domains where
you're bottlenecked not by actual
physical experiments or experimental
data, but from just
pure reasoning ability.
>> Mhm.
>> So,
wet labs, for example, are going to be a
bottleneck. I think in physics,
collecting the experimental data could
be a bottleneck. Uh
mathematics won't have that and the
question is like what other fields also
don't have that bottleneck.
I actually think
in some ways like things like AI
research, you know, it's debatable. Um
on the one hand,
you do like a lot of
research is bottlenecked by just having
a ton of GPUs and running large-scale
experiments. On the other hand, there is
a lot you can do with small-scale
experiments and small-scale resources.
And so, I am overall like pretty bullish
on the ability of AI models to be able
to like make progress on actual AI
research.
>> Do you think um so, you know, we're I
think we're about like 2 months out from
the next IMO.
Um
Do you sort of view this as the year
that it's you know, that sort of
saturates, so to speak? I think last
year
um the scores were already like 34 out
of 42, like clearly at the sort of gold
medal level. Um you know, I could
imagine sort of soon getting to the
point where the IMO becomes less
interesting as like a problem set to
solve because you just expect to kind of
like max out
um on every problem. And, you know, I
guess I'm curious what you view as like
the interesting frontier in contest
math. Um, you know, sort of if there is
still one left or if you sort of think
that to find interesting problems now
you kind of actually have to go to math
research.
>> I remember when we got the IMO gold last
year, um,
there was somebody from,
you know, another lab that texted me and
was like,
"So, do you think you'll get a perfect
score next year?"
And I told him like I'll be disappointed
if we don't have a model out by next
year that anybody can use to get a
perfect score on the IMO.
I I think
I would be surprised if we don't get a
perfect score with like our latest
internal models. I would also be I would
be disappointed if if it's possible that
I'd be disappointed if we don't get a
perfect score with like the released
models at this point.
Um,
so
I
don't think there's anything
I I think either now or pretty soon
competition math
competition coding is not going to be
interesting anymore.
And
the frontier really is actual unsolved
problems. Like actually doing real
research in the real world.
>> Um, yeah, maybe the right, you know,
sort of evaluation is just like can you
literally just upload the PDF of
problems to the publicly available, you
know, GPT-5.5 and, you know, sort of max
out. Maybe maybe that's sort of that's
the interesting thing um this year.
Um,
>> Yeah. I should also say like I don't
know we we never really mention it, but
we did
like our models have been able to solve
problem six from the IMO last year for a
while now. Uh, we decided not to like
advertise it because we just felt like
the field has already progressed beyond
competition math, but like we've been
able to get perfect scores on P6 for
several months.
>> I was going to ask about that because um
you know, so historically problem six is
like one of the harder problems and I
think even last year amongst sort of
like human participants maybe only six
people um got full marks um for it or
something. Um so I was curious if it was
if there was anything specific about
problem six um
you know, that sort of
um you know, made it less
sort of a like sort of it's harder to
solve for an AI system specifically or
is it just that it's uniformly harder
for humans and AI systems together and
we should just expect problem six to be
hard cuz it's sort of I remember
correctly it was this kind of
combinatorial tiling problem. I've heard
the argument in the past that like maybe
geometry sort of combinatorial geometry
problems are sort of particularly hard
because humans have so much visual
intuition, but yeah, I'm curious if you
if you think there's anything special
about problem six.
>> Uh it's a good question. I mean I I I
think it's kind of interesting how
much correlation there is between like
difficult for humans and difficult for
for AIs.
So I think that is a major factor that
it's just like look, it was a really
hard problem for humans and so in that
respect it's actually I guess not too
surprising that it's like a very
difficult problem for AI models. I think
it's also the nature of the problem that
I do think the models lag a bit when it
comes to like geometry um and just like
geometric understanding. Uh
but you know, the models just get better
across the board and they get better at
these things and so like it wasn't
surprising that you know, eventually the
models were just like suddenly able to
solve it.
>> Do you feel like there's sort of like a
different in kind um
chasm to cross between contest math and
research math? Like did you feel it sort
of you know,
in theory like the contest problems have
to be somewhat self-contained, you know,
there it has to be possible for a human
to sort of write a solution to them like
in an hour or something like that.
Um
but maybe kind of and you know, also I
think they tend to sort of favor
um
the sort of like certain known
techniques or tricks. Like if you get
really really good with the pigeonhole
principle, you know, there's sort of
always a couple of contest problems that
you can solve.
Um but I was curious if you felt like
any difference in kind on the AI
research side between sort of pointing
the model at contest math versus
pointing it at open research problems.
>> I I think there is a difference in
horizon I mean there's there's a
difference in horizon of the problem.
So, the IMO you have an hour and a half
to solve a problem. And one of the
things that my colleague Alex Way
pointed out, which I didn't realize at
the time but I think is really true in
retrospect, is that if you look at the
progression of AI models when it comes
to math, it it kind of follows this
trajectory of the model getting better
at uh
at like doing problems that would take a
human mathematician longer and longer.
So, if you think in like 2023
we were doing GSM8K. And GSM8K takes a
human mathematician like you know, 5
seconds.
>> Mhm.
>> And
then you in 2024 we're doing math. And
um
you know, that's
those problems they're like high school
level um
maybe like early college level and that
takes a human mathematician like maybe a
minute. And then you get to the AIME
that could take a human mathematician
maybe 10 minutes. And then you get to
the IMO and it takes a human
mathematician about an
100 minutes, about an hour and a half.
And you can just like basically every
year you
progress like an order of magnitude in
this respect. Like the horizon how long
it would take a human mathematician to
do it. And like there's reasons to think
maybe that trajectory doesn't continue
but it's like been continuing pretty
regularly so far.
And
so the difference between competition
math and research math is that research
math is over a much longer horizon.
>> Mhm.
>> But
it's also and I guess not surprising
that yeah, the models eventually are
able to do things
that would take a human mathematician
15 hours or or a week and it's just
the models have to become more capable.
I there is also a difference in that in
many ways the IMO was like adversarially
hard for AI models because, you know, we
discussed
there's
different
there's different strengths and
weaknesses of these AI models. Like
they're really good at knowing a bunch
of different areas of mathematics and
being able being able to combine results
from different fields. And then there's
the like being able to sit and work on a
difficult problem for a long period of
time and and just reason through it.
Where they're they're good, they're
getting better, uh but they I don't
wouldn't say that they're superhuman in
this respect yet. And the IMO really
emphasizes the second part. It's really
about It's not about knowing a bunch of
different areas of mathematics, it's
about sitting down and reasoning through
a very difficult problem for a long
time. And
and and that in that respect it's
actually like pretty interesting that
the model was getting a gold medal at
the IMO. And
I for that reason I think it's not
surprising that less than a year later
we're getting these like you know, this
the starts of proving results that
mathematicians cannot prove because we
already know, okay, it's a I it was at
IMO gold level in the ability to like
reason through hard problems a year ago
and it's or it was probably already
better at knowing a bunch of different
areas of mathematics and combining
results between them. So in that respect
like yeah, being able to do research
math
it probably isn't too surprising that it
happened so quickly.
>> Yeah, it's like you're sort of not able
to use things the models are best where
they have the most comparative advantage
relative to humans in the contest
setting.
And well, okay, maybe speculating a
little bit, what are human
mathematicians going to be doing in five
years? Like how does the job change? How
do you imagine people you know, sort of
will be spending their time?
Is it things like, you know, sort of
coming up with new research programs and
then just letting the model crank in the
background to see if there's a there
there over the next six hours? Um you
know, is it is it something different?
Yeah, I'm curious what you would
speculate, you know, sort of human
mathematicians are doing in whatever
time horizon you think is predictable.
>> Yeah, five five years is so far down the
road at this point that it's like I
don't know what the world looks like in
five years.
Uh I I can't speculate
what anything is like in five years.
Just because like progress is so fast.
>> Yeah.
>> I think a year or two from now,
um
I think a lot of mathematics is it it
kind of looks like the way coding is
today, where it's it's a lot of working
with the models. Um the models are doing
a lot of the work and you're kind of
like steering them um and pointing them
in the right direction and challenging
them and like
working with them to to
do these kinds of results. I In many
ways, I'm kind of surprised
that it didn't happen in mathematics
first. Um that's what I would have
expected actually.
Um but I don't think it's far behind
where where coding is today.
>> Um what happens next? You know, do you
sort of think um that maybe there's some
limited release of the model to sort of
human mathematicians to sort of make
progress in these areas. I'm curious how
you think about It makes total sense to
me that OpenAI's focus would be on
making the models better. Um
but you know, sort of if you were
looking just at math as a domain
um and sort of asking, you know, as
beyond OpenAI, just sort of as a
research community, um you know, how are
we going to make fast progress here over
the next year? What what sort of
um what's what's sort of about to
happen? What do you think are the next
steps?
>> We
after the IMO result, we actually did
discuss like should we make this model
available
um in advance to mathematicians.
And ultimately, it was just a matter of
like the bandwidth and and the
difficulty involved in doing that kind
of like custom deployment.
And also, I mean, progress is so fast.
We
we want to get the model out to
everybody.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh as quickly as possible. And so,
fast-tracking it for
a particular group, it introduces a lot
of complexity uh that I just don't think
is really worth the overhead. I think
it's better for us to just focus all
that effort into getting the model out
for everybody as fast as possible.
So,
um
I don't think I mean, maybe maybe we'll
do some like special cases, but I think
for the most part we're just really
focused on getting the model out to
everybody as quickly as possible. Um
and allowing everybody to use this thing
to to prove all sorts of crazy results.
>> Awesome.
Um well, you know, we're almost at time.
Is there anything that we didn't talk
about that you wanted to talk about? You
know, sort of anything that you think
it's important to to sort of understand
um or that you just want to call
attention to?
>> You know, one of the things I was I've
been thinking about ever since this
result is like
I it the proof is at a level that like
I'm not I mean, maybe if I really spent
a lot of time trying to understand it, I
would be able to understand it, but I
haven't really spent that that much
time. Um and I'm sure there's like a lot
of people that can't understand
the the proofs
um
for these kinds of results, let alone
proving it themselves.
And I think we're
as the models like become superhuman in
many respects, we're going to have this
problem where like the proofs themselves
are going to be
too difficult for human mathematicians
to verify.
>> Mhm.
>> And
I think this is a classic problem that's
basically scalable oversight. How do you
how do you get the models
to prove that the proof is correct to to
human mathematicians when the proof
itself is beyond what humans can really
comprehend.
>> Mhm.
>> I think
I'm excited for mathematics to be like
on the vanguard like be the vanguard for
for this kind of question of like how do
you do scalable oversight?
And
I think it's going to be uh
it's going to be like an interesting
problem and um one that I hope we can we
can figure out because I think it's
going to be important for a lot of other
domains as well.
>> Yeah. No, thanks for doing this. This
great.
>> It's been great.